well today it will be eric lauer on the
mound making his 10th start of the year
pitching in his 13th game
his record is three and four and he has
a solid 3.83 earned run average not a
hard thrower but he's got a very good
cut fastball that can really tie up both
right-handers and left-handers lauer
deals again this one is hit in the air
again into very shallow right
and avi garcia plenty of time to get
there on that one
tour up to her down and salvador perez
coming up paris strikes out great start
for lauer low inside off speed offering
the young right-hander 25 years old soon
to be 26 last year had a great year 247
era but it's been a struggle this season
there's a called third strike and keller
begins his day with a strikeout keller
they've stayed with him look at that
singer good night
yeah got him with a good sinking
fastball struck him out great first
inning for brad keller two strikeouts in
a fly out we head to the second inning
of play 3-2 delivery from eric lauer
here he comes swinging in a fly ball
shallow left
yelich coming on calling
adamus off on that one and makes the
catch
two are up two are down five in a row
now for eric lauer and here is jorge
solaire lauer kicks and deals again and
that one is hit in the air this time
williams is calling off christian yelich
six in order for eric lauer inning and a
half complete nothing nothing so two
down to jace peterson swinging the smash
up the middle base hit
for peterson came in at 2 54. pick up a
point or two there keller getting to
sign now back to work and gets a
fastball breaks the bat the ball rolls
to nikki lopez he grabs it and fires to
first base marias is out and so are the
milwaukee brewers we head to the third
inning of play
and as we begin ending number three in a
scoreless game it is michael a taylor
there's strength three called over the
outside corner good fastball from eric
lauer 3-2 swinging a miss fastball right
down the middle it was down on the count
3-1 but strikes out the royal shortstop
back-to-back case first played
appearance of the year for brad keller
the big power right-hander
and lauer makes quick work of him he
strikes out the side rock solid so far
looking for some runs on the home half
of the ledger bradley batted twice
yesterday and was one for two it has
been a big struggle for him at the plate
oh and two keller staying on the attack
now another o2
and there's a strike called on the
outside corner at 95. brad keller has
strike at number three on the day
3-2 and a swing and a miss and a slider
and brad keller after falling behind
three-and-oh comes back to strike out
colton wong here's the 2-1
yelich line drive center field base hit
lauer is going to put on the brakes at
second yelling with a soft single first
and second with two outs now for willy
adams here comes his 40th pitch
and a fastball is hit to the third
baseman dozier he'll fire across to
santana
and the patented brad keller ground ball
ends the threat and the brewers strand
two in the fourth we go so runner at
second nobody out there's the swing of
the miss lauer comes right back gets his
fifth k of the day and the little mini
slump will continue for santana now
three for his last 28.
chased one down he goes
lauer back-to-back case his last five
out singing are via the strikeout job
not done yet as ben intended comes to
the plate lauer about throws 59th pitch
on the day and here comes the 1-1 and a
swing and a fastball line down the
left-field line and that is a fair ball
down into the corner with merrifield
coming around third he will come in and
score and andrew benintendi with the
royals first hit on the day doubles and
drives in the first run of the day for
either side one nothing royals
that's hit to left field and down in
front of yelich and with two outs ben
attendees going on contact so dozier
does come through
and the royals take a two-nothing lead
in the fourth omar narayans will leave
things off for milwaukee and their half
of the fourth and the pitch from keller
called strike three on the outside
corner of fastball brad keller has
struck
[Applause]
so whit
was in the area he wasn't right there it
was still a difficult play but close
enough and a nice long one hop throw to
carlos santana one two from keller
swing and a foul held on to by salvador
perez and beginning is over two more
strikeouts for brad keller give him six
in the game so big opportunity here for
the brew crew with two on and nobody out
and rally teles here's the one two teles
leans down on one right center deep
michael a taylor is there but plenty
deep to score a run
and the brewers are on the board
as telez with a sac fly at an rbi in a
pinch-hit roll what a spot here for
christian yelich tying rod at second
bottom of the fifth that ball's ripped
down the line it goes
in the score is bradley and it's going
to be an rbi double fourth christian
yelich we're tied at two
adamus jam shot coming home is long and
he will score and the brewers have the
lead long running on contacts
adamus drives in the run
on the 6-3 ground out but the brewers
have put three on the board
royal is in business now two on with one
out
and now a line drive and that'll be into
left field coming around third as carlos
santana and hunter dozier he has driven
in two and the royals have tied it at
three in the sixth inning royals at
every base now nikki lopez is due up
here's the 1-0 and he swings and shoots
it to right field that's going to be all
the way bouncing up against the fence
over the head of the right fielder
garcia one run is in two runs are in
mcbroom stops at third it's a two-run
double for nikki lopez and the royals
lead this game five to three the royals
have at the corners with one down now
the battle will be ben attendee you
drove in a run with a double there's a
swing adam is ben and tendy strikes out
cousins just kept at him with that
slider 1-2 pitch and he got him
struck him out with a slider
back-to-back case with two on jorge
solaire will lead things off
solaire golfs one into deep left field
and that is way out of here and jorge
soler has holbert in back-to-back games
and the royals have a three-run lead in
the eighth inning barlow who's collected
four saves a little bit of closer by
committee these days with mike matheny
and holland yesterday barlow gets a
chance today
pulled on the ground to wit college
teammate throws out college teammate
and it's a clean sweep for the royals
they go 4-0 against the first place
brewers